plus we're very close to a vaccine very
close to a therapeutic
uh i've heard that name mentioned we'll
find out i can get back to you later
okay
we're trying to work it into the
schedule i want to see the people
i love the people of iowa they've been
very loyal and the big thing was getting
the declaration signed
but i'll be going very soon and maybe
today steven
are you uh it's terrible
that's a terrible situation belarus
uh we'll be following it very closely
we'll be followed
did you hear about that no i haven't
heard them
looking at the brazilian situation we'll
take care of all of them
okay so we'll see you in a little while
[Music]
what's your goal well we're going to be
stopping at a number of places
we'll be uh working very hard
uh it doesn't have to be covered but it
probably will be
you know but we're going to be working
very hard stopping at various states you
have a list of the states
uh pretty comprehensive we're going to
be working very hard
we have to we're getting down to final
crunch
we want to be there as an example iowa
just came up
we're doing well in iowa it just came up
i want to be with the people of iowa so
we add that to the schedule
probably uh on friday we're looking at
friday
and we may do just a small service right
here in the white house for my brother
we're looking at doing that that would
be i think a great honor to him
i think he'd be greatly honored he loves
our country he loved our country so much
he was so proud of what we were doing
and what we are doing for our country so
i think it would be appropriate so we'll
we'll have probably on friday afternoon
a
small service in honor of my brother
robert
no i think this i think that nancy
pelosi and
chuck schumer should get back into
washington and they should
approve stimulus for the people they
should give
we should give some of the this was
china's fault it wasn't their fault
and we'd like to see payment going to
the people maybe ppe
but we want paper payment going to the
people
we'll take care of the post office we
want to make sure
that the post office runs properly and
it hasn't run properly for many years
for
probably 50 years it's run very badly
so we want to make sure that the post
office runs properly
and it lose billions of dollars somebody
said it lost 78 billion dollars over a
relatively short period of time that's
over years
78 billion dollars so you can't have
that no
we will work with them but we want money
to go to the people that need it
and they don't want to do that they just
want to take care of the
bailout money they want bailout money to
go to their friends that are doing a bad
job running democrat states
a lot of money they've been poorly run
by democrats for many years
and that's all they want to talk about
is bailing out those states
that's unfair to the rest of the country
are going to affect are you worried
about cutbacks through service affecting
people getting medications
and prescriptions no no the post office
is running very well
the post office now look if you look at
the post office
for years that's all people complained
about we're going to run it well and
we're going to not lose so much money
one of the things the post office loses
so much money on
is delivering packages for amazon and
these others
every time they deliver a package they
probably lose three or four dollars
that's not good they have to raise those
prices okay
not for the people to pay but for amazon
and those companies to pay
thank you very much
why are you opposed to mail in dallas
when they cannot be
packed by exploring interpreters
absentee ballots are great
you request a ballot you can't be i
signed an absentee ballot
absentee ballots are great they work
they've been proven they're good like in
florida
but this universal mail-in is a very
dangerous thing
it's fraught with fraud
i feel that way so we have to be very
careful with this universal mail-in
ballot
absentee ballots are great they've
worked for a long time
and i i totally endorse absentee ballots
thank you very much
a big donor to you to slow the mail no
not at all
wouldn't do that no i i have encouraged
everybody
speed up the mail not slow the mail and
i also want to have a post office
that runs without losing billions and
billions of dollars a year
as it has been doing for 50 years thank
you